mais que fait le loup une histoire de
joëlle ecormier illustré par michel
boucher aux éditions océan jeunesse il
calcule le chemin le plus court pour
aller chez mère-grand il hurle à la lune
comme un hurluberlu
il adore se déguiser n'aime pas ses
oreilles
il essaye de les cacher il écoute en
boucle le message de son répondeur je
suis absent mais laissez moi votre
adresse
et je vous mangerez dès mon retour il
fait un peu de couture
il en a assez qu'on les découpe le
ventre tous les quatre matins il compte
les moutons
miam miam miam
il commence une thérapie pour lutter
contre ces fins de nous il marche à pas
de loup du coup elle est toujours en
retard ils répètent une scène importante
tire la chevillette tire la bobinette la
chevrette tire la bobinette la
chevillette sera tire la bobinette la
cheville est cher a pu d'abord ça veut
dire quoi tout ce charabia
juste une fois
il aimerait bien avoir le rôle du petit
gentils loups de l'histoire il ne
supporte plus les questions indiscrètes
loup y es tu que fais tu m'entends tu
il préfère les questions existentielles
qui a peur du grand méchant joue il
s'imagine en jeune loup aux dents
longues aussi connu que le loup blanc
il se fait engager par mange ta soupe
sinon gare au loup points comme il faut
bien gagner sa vie
il joue à cache cache seras tu le
trouver
il se perd il rêve de dormir tranquille
près d'un bon feu de cheminée comme un
bon gros toutou il prendrait bien sa
retraite sur un bateau pour finir sa
carrière en vieux loup de mer
il lit une histoire de grand méchant
chasseurs à ces petits loups et après
ils arrivent